6 25 in your monday morning residential
neighborhood speeding again now both
metro and north las vegas police did
recently take some street racers into
custody up in the northwest valley that
may be a start but for folks like han he
wrote an email showing there's still a
very real problem in many parts of town
he writes the stretch of hammer lane
between allen and simmons well he's got
speeding at near freeway speeds along
was skipping the stop sign there at
farrell completely skipping it burnouts
donuts in the area he says really
looking for help here before people end
up in a fatal crash or a car ends up in
somebody's living room han thanks for
writing in i'm happy to pass you note
along to the north las vegas police i
can also tell you that in the most
recent publicized crackdown having video
of the problem was a big help to
investigators although your safety is
most important buckle up drive carefully
please put down that phone something's
driving you crazy email me traffic
news now dot com